if I were to differentiate again hence
second derivative okay that would tell
you how dy/dx is changing okay so that's
what the second derivative means so
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna call
the second derivative of a weird name
I'll explain in a second but it's an
important piece of notation to get down
d squared Y on DX squared that's
mysterious
there's lots of different ways to say in
the second rooms but I think this is the
best water to derive in a standoff with
it
what's it equal to all I'm gonna do is
take this derivative and differentiate
again okay
so 3x squared bring the power down and
you reduce it by one so you just get 6x
and the 1 of course is a cost that's so
advantageous okay so what does this mean
let me get another color and let's put
this on 6x where is this mmm I'm
guessing it's somewhere like my scale is
gonna be a bit off but you get the
general
is it I need to stand back I can see it
okay
unless you have a good party game now
I'll treat back those huh I've got three
guys on here right number one I've got
my actual graph why in green I've got
the derivative the vestiges and the
first term tells me what's the blue
graph changing like what has a behavior
and this black graph tells me how the
green graph is changing now can you see
what's going on have a look at a 6x
right have a look for X is less than
zero this second derivative is negative
okay what that corresponds to it is the
first derivative is decreasing you see
that increasing at a decreasing rate
okay
so what this is small sorry about that
what this is saying is I put this back
increasing if the derivative is
decreasing okay that means that the
second derivative is negative you see
that it sits below the axis the black
rappers below the actors so the
derivative is getting smaller and then
when you pass the origin the dreamers
starts getting bigger again which is why
the black graph is positive so that's
this part yeah okay so how's your brain
good Herman uh we're trying to think
about this in terms of the first movie
and how it's changing okay there's
another way to think about this I want
you to look back again a blue graph okay
there's not just a change in the green
graph with the blue graph you can also
describe geometrically increasing and
decreasing leads going up or down
right but I introduced this idea of
concavity
cavity from cavity important word wasn't
mean we're talking about like lenses
right like you don't like lenses okay
we usually say they're concave or
they're convex concave or commas so I
think if my memory serves concave is the
one that goes in because like a cave
right and convex in the other one yes
right so we're talking about we're
talking about this one it's left hand
one okay so it's a back have a look at
this carefully right see this part of
the graph it has a concavity right it's
sort of like a like a part of the lens
right which direction is it going in
which direction is there facing
okay well if you cover the rest of the
graph you just think you know it's um
yeah it's it's kind of pinpoint in that
direction right but we're just thinking
about positives and negatives okay so I
would call this part of the graph
concave down in other words if you try
to like a pour water on this okay it
would all sort of none of it would sit
there or walk rush off okay so this part
is concave down this part over here is
concave up you see how it's sort of
facing another direction now I know in
this case if I am if I pour water on
this we're also good away right but if I
if I actually continued this shape who
form like a cup and it would sit there
okay and you can think of more obviously
tip because like say the one we looked
at earlier execute - it's the same idea
but more pronounced but can you see it
the left hand side to the left of the
origin is concave down
that's um this pot here facing downwards
okay and then once you pass the origin
you are now facing upwards okay you see
that
so click Avenue who daddy comes from the
second derivative it's another way of
saying I'm increasing but I'm a DS at
decreasing rate that's concave down or
I'm increasing but
increasing rate that's cocaine off okay
so contaminate gradient these are the
two geometric ideas that correspond to
our first derivative and our second
interview okay so I actually put them in
the mess all up sorry this is the second
derivative and this is the first